1. Start with a rectangle with 1:2 proportions.
Don't make a square flag. Looking at you, Vatican City.
2. Use simple shapes and maybe a silhouette to create symbolism for what the flag represents.
Never use seals or complex designs that can't be drawn by a child in several seconds.
3. Keep the design simple, while still differentiating it from other flags.
4. Use 2 or 3 colors that look good together.
You may want to consider using lighter colors, which tend to look better.
5. A good flag is recognizable backwards, and in many other scenarios.
One trick to make sure a flag can be recognized
even when sitting still on a pole, rather than it flying in the wind,
is to make a unique design element in the canton, the top left corner.
Seem familiar? Well, probably because it is.
I hope you now know a little bit more about vexillology.
If you found this interesting, follow the links in the notes for some cool related pages and sites. Good day!